[Applause]
right here he's trying to make Robin a
poster and wouldn't know we're close to
the rim good try though good effort by
Beasley but Levine looks thinner and
more fit he played very well in the
preseason again one of the differences
will be attacking from the middle of the
floor as opposed to elbows and corners
at time be honest uh Brook Lopez and
that's a good strong finish
goodness slope as who went six for six
in the first quarter but soon they did
that beautiful mouth Lopez for hanging
on the rim after the duck under his feet
voice oh Jesus
done / - sachi
oh my game I need to see a chiropractor
after that one oh my goodness and Lopez
again here it is this roll to the basket
rolls to the basket big fella his
parents moved actually to the Bay Area
three years ago from Wisconsin to be
close to their son is Lopez gets it to
drop plus it was funny on the play
big Brook Lopez with the James Harden
sticks those arms out gets low knee to
commit and one very nice crafty play by
the big fella I could do that
[Applause]
now kicks it out Lopez
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
two in the second period it's been a
strange game there's no doubt I would
not have thought after an eight point
first
so far no now Blake he dumps it into it
Robin gallops into the lane coolly
would be proud himself out and I've been
saying this all along with with the
Bulls big guys whether it be win Dale
Carter jr. Robin Lopez
[Music]
[Applause]
there comes Booker he's right on me
that's got there at the last second
marker - Archie piano give me the hot
close arts its remaining in the second
quarter shut down stop every gardener's
on his back
look Brooke - and what he's done so well
as your what a block and make truthfully
Ward just holds onto the boy so strong
it whips us down at the block that he
ends up on his back ball it's tough and
his one
[Applause]
I'm shocked at home wash in the history
I'm the other Lopez get in here man the
first time sneak ball Brook Lopez at the
long arms picked off his feet using that
left arm and then he just sorts that
dunk attempt and then here's Brooke and
omits inside like if market and credit
like a gun cold-blooded right they're
[Applause]
both heads in the weak side corner it
came out to the break on the three-point
line he gets a pass and nails it back
out dribble drive try to walk along
those feet the mule Pez we must not
already scatter reports and badly right
here welcome to the NBA trying to go up
and Robin Lopez no soup for you nice
fine the Lopez bangs it in plus the foul
throwing a pocket bounce pass in traffic
we'd try to feed Lopez double
right around Bob up for the slam and
Chicago right back in it Simmons barrels
in and leave the friend be got that I by
Lopez we set to 14 the Rosen driving a
lot by Lopez and picked up by Holliday
[Applause]
to coupon a good finish by Lopez she
tried to sell our e up out court in a
hard drive
those who value
way ours he goes it's Robin Lopez come
here and says I know it's the holidays
and it's cold outside but there's no
soup for you
Gordon trying to slip strong coaching
staff they all love havin Delhi back in
the Polo Drive and flush Brook Lopez and
I assume that still includes TV
announcer Fred McCloud people marketing
and Lopez play catch out front
[Music]
Oh Dario Dario action
what's this pass right here throws it up
go get it big two on the shot clock
Lopez why not slowly methodically Brook
Lopez worked himself into great position
season I have 36 look with knows a shot
clock is winding down right there's a
space creator one-legged down on Lopez
against town bullies him into the lane
cioppino the crowd two weeks almost
every time Robin
touches the ball he scores five on the
shot clock
last court pass almost ripped away I
tell you what you gotta lumbers through
there but he gets it done
here's Lopez like he was hammered on
that play as well inside Mahinmi and
Lopez knocked it free is not numbers
nice step through off the glass and it
goes home for Antonio Blake back to the
block
that's what he was upset after enjoying
what you're doing out on the floor put
food hoses insistence that this team
playoff got the green light is truth any
open three points that you want to Lopez
back it down vehement may be leaning
here comes the double he was but he was
Eddie hits the shot and Lopez seeing a
little guys thinking I'm gonna go to
work down here but Fred vanvleet
we want a good job surge getting the
extra pass Jenny Osmond knocks it down
I'm a taint I done swings one into Lopez
smalls Millhone Pratt bounders are out
of position and for a guy like Colbert
at his left seven for wingspan nine
seven standing retail snaps a three
that's my hat around the screen puts on
the brakes
be proud to Brogdon the president in
Washington backs out
good defense by the Wizards Brook Lopez
a deep three to open the game so however
you want to say it ten fewer games that
Blake Griffin inside for the stuff Brook
Lopez David bring one with the crowd
power move on Brian we mentioned it last
night in in our pregame pass hits a late
shot clock fadeaway great post on the
break got its it done I to three now a
drive hits underneath the Lopez course
and follow a nice right here nice short
quick came in 35 pounds he could play
make some out there Lopez with the
floating Jam that he's underneath
I mean you don't want to step on a foot
sprain an ankle I mean there's no one
directly underneath them but understand
he's concerned about coming down the
robbers plunge
[Music]
without watch Larry right here with the
wrap pass and then Robin goes up there's
a hack by Nikko and then right there
that's losing at Oklahoma City back late
January to 27 we're talking 16 of 18
wins overall since January 13th best
catch the mouse they force the switch
errors in
[Music]
[Applause]
so again
draw the charge they need give it to me
so that similar to wouldn't work those
would he knocks down three at his little
routine abrooke acknowledges not at all
comes down to Lopez with Danny is young
I didn't see this kind of success come
in this game three moment ago was the
first
[Music]
well but pick that little hand off off
the drill even though on its face the
dribble weave and then kind of crosses
over and I think he's just caught the
entire game in terms of whatever a
desolate you beg defensively liquid tune
scoring and now focus here in the third
you may not need to make as many hole
solutions were here as Gulliver's
Travels Neal you got it
off another ball not knowing where it
would jaw with just making Lopez react
yet here on the big fella boys had both
ends of the floor and cluding the
whirling Robin Lopez they add layers to
it as they go through the season so two
different styles but great effect the
one thing I love about what but is done
is he's giving you principles and
concepts in which you can
playing Lopez against Tsubasa
a sweeping left hand right now he's he's
put on clinic
let's--oh on the pick Lopez very deep
three yes Levine's active aim of the
game my tension zach lavine with that
blouse pretty much had his way with the
bucks the first half of this game
running out George Hill here's a good
job with Lopez detective that is $50 for
just printing out right-wing phrase it
nice job little shovel action to what
genders it has done Lowery parking it
with some muscle
Lopez tracks it down there's the
minister how about the past by Lopez he
honest out of the paint don't allow him
to get out in transition and that starts
with you really operating to be well how
about that play off of that Middleton to
Lopez the alley if they're just great
execute swerves into the lane stops and
then got the air and drop it off so
Robert
[Music]
a great Tomball we will be proud of that
move this position right here seal them
right here Leonard is be all he's got to
do now just go up strong take the
contact on one good move by Robin Lopez
Lopez meanwhile and you saw the Jazz
will look to get on the board next here
on ESPN nice delivery Lopez Celia Silva
lemon driving with a left hand
no and put back the Y Rob and he's got
six out of five on the shot clock
Lopez on the drive
[Applause]
[Applause]
Lopez spinning twisting twisting man's
gone Kareem abdul-jabbar would be proud
lemon I believe there's a look at Robyn
there's a footwork right there another
foul on Walt what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content